[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in allen an den
öffentlichen gebäuden in der ukraine
hängt neben der landesfahne schon die
der eu das land sieht sich auf gutem weg
und in der tat die ukraine hat heute
eine erste hürde genommen
ja die ukraine verdient eine europäische
perspektive
ja die ukraine sollte als
beitrittskandidat willkommen geheißen
werden denn gute arbeit wurde schon
geleistet aber es bleibt noch wichtige
arbeit zu tun hat important workouts
remains to be done
man könnte auch sagen viele weitere
hürden und vor allem dürfte der
europäische traum für die menschen in
der ukraine noch jahre oder gar
jahrzehnte entfernt sein wenn es so
läuft wie bislang immer aber vielleicht
läuft es ja nicht wie bislang immer es
tun sich heute generell viele neue
fragezeichen auf angespannt so
bezeichnet die zuständige
bundesnetzagentur heute zum ersten mal
die versorgungslage beim gas in
deutschland
angespannt sind auch die nerven von uns
allen die gaspreise für private
haushalte haben sich im vergleich zu vor
dem krieg bereits jetzt vervielfacht und
sie kennen weiter nur eine richtung nach
oben
russland drosselt aktuell seine
gaslieferungen massiv präsident wladimir
putin zeigt sich überzeugt dass er den
kampf um die energie gewinnen wird und
spricht überhaupt von einer neuen
weltordnung peter kunz mit mehr
welten liegen zwischen wladimir putin
und dem westen aber auch zwischen dem
westen und dem bild das der russische
präsident davon hat
kraftstrotzender verbaler angriff beim
sankt petersburger wirtschaftsforum dem
davos seiner welt
die usa die sich für den sieger im
kalten krieg halten sehen sich selbst
als die abgesandten gottes auf der erde
die keine pflichten haben nur interessen
die sie als heilig begreifen
westliche länder würden andere wie
kolonien behandeln schimpft putin aber
die welt ändere sich gerade
der wirtschaftlichen blitzkrieg gegen
russland ist gescheitert erklärte putin
heute nachmittag
und tatsächlich muss manches weltbild
von seinem russland unter sanktionen
korrigiert werden der rubel so stark wie
seit jahren nicht mehr riesen profite
durch die gestiegenen öl- und gaspreise
russland schafft turbulenzen auf dem
internationalen gasmarkt und treibt die
preise noch höher indem es seine
gaslieferungen quer durch europa immer
weiter einschränkt oder einstellt in
polen bulgarien dänemark finnland den
niederlanden deutschland italien
österreich und nun auch in der slowakei
und frankreich was moskau den europäern
an gas kürzt ist für den russischen
präsidenten kein verlustgeschäft es wird
auch gegen den politischen gewinn
verrechnet vor allem deutschland soll
angst haben vor einem winter ohne
heizung und wir haben uns auf diese
situation vorbereitet mit gesetzen dem
gasspeicher gesetzt mit den
möglichkeiten andere kraftstoffe
einzusetzen aber natürlich muss ich auch
sagen dass der ausbau erneuerbarer
energien und vor allem jetzt das
kurzzeitige einsparen von energie sehr
sehr hilft sparen wo machbar gas zu
kaufen womöglich an gas weltweit ist
kein mangel es muss nur hierher nach
deutschland das sich wie ein junkie an
die russischen pipelines gehängt hat im
gegensatz zu europäischen nachbarn keine
flüssiggas infrastruktur besitzt und
jetzt um lieferungen kämpft
gas fließt nach deutschland aber
natürlich wenn die unterschiedlichen
länder auf unterschiedliche
lieferquellen zurückgreifen dann gibt es
einen wettbewerb und deswegen ist auch
eine europäische koordinierung hier so
wichtig damit wir eben auch als europa
zusammen stehen und nicht der eine den
anderen ausbreitet putins spaltpilz
damit seine strategie nicht aufgeht
müssen die gasspeicher in deutschland
wie der grösste hier im
niedersächsischen rehden bis zum herbst
voll sein und gegen die russiche
preistreiberei soll jetzt ein kredit
rettungsschirm helfen die regierung hat
mit einem großen entlastungspaket mit
einem großen solvenz schirm hier auch
hilfen angekündigt das ist richtig aber
man wird sehr genau schauen müssen ob
die richtigen getroffen werden ob den
richtigen geholfen werden kann oder ob
es weitere entlastungspaket
insbesondere für die braucht die im
winter in eine echte finanzielle notlage
kommen das heißeste thema des sommers
wie kommen wir alle warm durch diesen
nächsten winter
ja den drohenden gas mangel für
deutschland managen muss die
bundesnetzagentur in bonn ihre chefs
klaus müller guten am himmel
ag ist herr sievers die lieferungen
durch nord stream eins hat russland
jetzt auf 40 prozent gedrosselt russland
sagt wegen reparaturarbeiten von
verdichter turbinen die müssen offenbar
tatsächlich repariert werden ist also an
dieser begründung was dran
richtig ist dass diese turbinen
regelmäßig gewartet werden müssen ab und
zu auch repariert werden müssen nur wir
sehen keine begründung kein zusammenhang
der die kürzung um jetzt 60 prozent
rechtfertigen würde insofern überzeugt
uns diese begründung nicht also sie
sagen hier eine politische begründung
und keine technische wie gut kommen wir
denn dann mit dieser kürzung um 60
prozent klar wenn das jetzt so
weitergeht
naja das ist der grund warum die
bundesnetzagentur heute erstmalig von
einer angespannten situation berichtet
hat wir haben ungefähr 1000
gigawattstunden pro tag weniger das
betrifft nicht nur deutschland das
betrifft auch die länder durch die wir
dann gas weiter leiten sie haben
frankreich zu recht benannt aber
insgesamt kommt jetzt deutlich weniger
gas bei uns an das heißt die gasspeicher
wurden jetzt nicht mehr so stark gefüllt
wir uns das in den letzten tagen und
wochen gelungen ist und das ist ein
problem weil wir wollen richtungen 90 +6
kennen
schaffen wir den 90 +6 mit der aktuellen
lage noch
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage wenn ich
das wüsste würde ich wahrscheinlich
gerade ruhiger schlafen wir haben eine
situation dass eben weniger gas ankommt
wir noch nicht wissen wie viel gas
eingespeichert wird wir sehen wie zur
zeit der preis nach oben geht das macht
es gerade nicht leichter andererseits
führt das auch dazu dass vielleicht
weniger gas verbraucht wird also sind
mehrere gegenläufige entwicklungen ich
kann ihnen das heute nicht sagen aber
ich kann ihnen sagen die werden alles
dafür tun dass wir das ziel erreichen
alles was in unserer macht steht herr
müller selbst wenn die speicher
knallvoll wären würden wir damit über
den winter kommen
noch eine gute frage wenn tatsächlich
speicher rechnerisch bei 100 prozent
wären dann ist das ungefähr bei einem
durchschnittlichen winter der bedarf in
deutschland von zweieinhalb monaten wenn
wir auf russisches gas verzichten
müssten komplett aber weiß jemand wann
der winter beginnt vanendert wie kalt
wie warm er wird wissen wir ob wir in
einer notlage sind ob unsere
europäischen nachbarn für die es eine
solidaritäts verpflichtung gibt es sind
einfach zu viele unbekannte insofern
kann das keiner seriös vorhersagen was
wir tun können wir appellieren dringend
jede eingesparte kubikmeter gas ist gut
fürs klima gut für den geldbeutel gut
für die vorsorge an der situation
und insofern bitten wir die industrie
bitten wir die privaten verbraucher
alles zu tun was möglich ist sie bitten
jetzt ist es aber so dass die
unternehmen bereits horrorszenarien
gezeichnet haben falls gas fehlt da ist
die rede vom verlust ganzer
industriesparten
wie beurteilen sie das kann die
industrie das irgendwie doch im griff
behalten oder drohte eine wirkliche
katastrophe
ja auch das kommt eben leider sehr sehr
darauf an was jetzt in der nächsten
wochen und monaten passiert wäre mir
zwar ungefähr zwölf wochen dann beginnt
die heizsaison zurzeit an gas einsparen
zu denken ist angesichts der tollen
sommerlichen temperaturen schon
schwierig aber drei monate sind nicht
viel richtig ist dass wenn die
bundesregierung eine gas notlage
ausrufen würde weil zu wenig gas da wäre
dass dann das europäische recht gilt und
dann müsste die bundesnetzagentur hier
eingreifen und die besonderen
geschützten verbrauchergruppen sind
private haushalte krankenhäuser
pflegeheime das heißt da würden wir
nicht drangehen wollen aber
industriezweige industriebetriebe
müssten wir gegebenenfalls abschalten
auch wenn das keiner will wenn einfach
schlicht zu wenig gas da ist darum tut
die bundesregierung ja alles dafür um
neues gas zu bekommen das sind die lng
terminal ist die sie genannt haben wenn
wir zwei schwimmende terminals noch in
diesem winter bekommen würden das würde
uns sehr helfen dass wir einen
riesenschritt nach vorne jetzt haben sie
gerade eben gesagt private haushalte
würden sie aus nehmen an die würden sie
nicht rangehen zumindest erst mal nicht
können sie ausschließen es ist eine
etwas komische frage bei den aktuellen
temperaturen aber so lange ist es ja
nicht mehr hin sie haben es angesprochen
können sie ausschließen dass menschen
frieren werden im winter bei uns in
ihren wohnungen
also ich kann ihnen zusichern dass wir
alles dafür tun werden dass das nicht
der fall sein wird und darum ist eben
der dringende appell und ich bitte
sozusagen auch die dringlichkeit in
meiner stimme ernst zu nehmen alles was
man jetzt schon einsparen kann selbst in
den sommermonaten das hilft wenn der
herbst kommt ein bisschen sozusagen auf
die temperaturen einen heizung zu achten
das hilft gleichermaßen die industrie
wir appellieren jetzt schon zu
substituieren zu ersetzen zu überlegen
wo kann man mit anderen stoffen
auskommen im bundestag wird beraten dass
ein gesetz auf den weg gebracht werden
soll um nicht mehr gas zur verstromung
zu benutzen sondern kohle das flüssiggas
haben wir eben schon erwähnt also die
bundesregierung tut gerade ganz ganz
viel dafür industrie private haushalte
können mit unterstützen damit
deutschland gut durch die nächsten
winter kommt und so bitter es ist der
nächste winter wird kommen das stimmt
und wir hören auch die dringlichkeit in
ihrer stimme herr müller unterm strich
wenn man das alles so hört was wir uns
gerade gesagt haben sitzt vladimir putin
aktuell noch am längeren hebel was die
energie angeht
sie haben vorhin ihren beitrag in see
härte vokabel benutzt ich glaube es ging
richtung drogenmilieu mit dem sie
deutschland verglichen haben fakt ist
deutschland ist zur zeit noch abhängig
die bundesregierung minister habe tut
alles dafür dass wir unabhängiger von
fossilen vom russischen gas werden an
der stelle dass es gut für den
klimaschutz gut für unsere vorsorge ist
es gut für unseren geldbeutel ist es gut
aber um sich von dieser abhängigkeit zu
reduzieren brauchen wir zeit und die
zeit wird wahrscheinlich länger sein als
der nächste winter und darum sage ich ja
wir sind angespannt und in einer
angespannten situation klaus müller der
chef der bundesnetzagentur es wird nicht
das letzte mal gewesen sein dass wir
miteinander reden herr müller für heute
ganz herzlichen dank nach bonn
ich danke ihnen
ja und auch das passt dazu die mehrheit
der deutschen rechnet mit einem
abwärtstrend die wirtschaftliche lage in
deutschland bezeichnen nur noch 22
prozent als gut das sind so wenige wie
seit 12 jahren nicht mehr das aktuelle
zdf-politbarometer mit allen zahlen
gleich nach uns das barometer bei afg
parteitagen schlägt traditionell heftig
aus selbst wenn es um die wahl einer
neuen parteispitze geht ist der zeitplan
und vorhersehbar auf dem parteitag in
riesa soll es jetzt morgen soweit sein
es könnte künftig und erstmals auch nur
noch eine person an der spitze stehen da
wird gepaart mit mehr dazu
timo grub allah weiß dass er verbündete
brauchen wird um den parteitag in riesa
am ende wieder als vorsitzender
verlassen zu können es lief zuletzt
überhaupt nicht zehn wahlen in ländern
und dem bund verstolpert mitglieder
verloren das image als ideenlose
dagegen-partei zementiert
die letzten zehn wahlen mit ungefähr
einem wählerschwund von 20
wie abgeschlossen haben die mitglieder
sind ausgetreten weil sie mit der
politischen und programmatischen führung
dieser partei in den letzten ein zwei
jahren vollkommen unzufrieden waren
führen kommt durch kompetenz und da muss
man einfach mal sagen das sind wir an
uns selbst zum teil gescheitert
zwischendurch gerät der parteitag zum
scherbengericht katerstimmung einer
partei in der sinnkrise kein
gewinnerthema
innerparteilicher dauerstreit kubala
beschwört den neuanfang
die destruktive stimmung der vergangenen
zeit hinter uns lassen auf diesem
parteitag muss ein bundesvorstand
gewählt werden der kollegial und
konstruktiv vertrauens und
rücksichtsvoll zusammenarbeit wir müssen
nach außen geschlossen auftreten weil
ansonsten hast es der wähler und er
hasst es so recht eine prise
selbstkritik von den beiden
fraktionschefs die sich morgen zusammen
an die parteispitze wählen lassen wollen
entweder als duo oder sie als erste
stellvertreterin von ihm eine heute
beschlossene satzungsänderung würde
erstmals die einer spitze möglich machen
doch copala alleine trauen die viele
nicht zu ersetzen dafür die wahl
zwischen einer und zweier spitze wir
machen das jetzt fix für die satzung wir
machen in diesen durchlauf nochmal eine
zweier spitze fordert etwa der
rechtsextreme björn rücker der selbst
wohl diesmal noch vor einer kandidatur
zurückschreckt und im schatten von
propeller und weil seine
bundespolitische macht anderweitig
ausbauen will das will unter anderem er
verhindern norbert kleinwächter ist
einer von mindestens zwei
gegenkandidaten für die parteispitze er
gilt als eher gemäßigt und erschossen
das ist jetzt eine partei sollte es
sympathischer werden und freundlicher
werden weil wir auch am infostand merken
dass wir oft nicht ausreichend
sympathisch oder freundlich wahrgenommen
werden und deswegen sollten wir da
natürlich an unsere mitarbeiter morgen
also entscheidet die afg über ihr
spitzenpersonal ist dürfte ein offenes
schließen werden prophezeit ein
funktionär und die nächste heute
so hanna du hast jetzt den blick auf
einen weiteren wichtigen besucher im
präsidentenpalast zog er von dort war
heute nämlich der britische premier
johnson zu gast und hat dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky weitere
militärhilfe zugesagt genauso wie die
möglichkeit der ausbildung der
ukrainischen soldaten an den neuen
waffen bei dem treffen sagte johnson
dass er an der seite der ukraine stehe
um dem land die strategische ausdauer zu
geben die gebraucht werde es ist bereits
das zweite mal seit kriegsbeginn dass
johnson nach kiew gereist ist
großbritanniens regierung hat nach
jahrelangem juristischen tauziehen die
auslieferung von wikileaks gründer
julian assange an die usa angewiesen
gegen die verfügung wollen seine anwälte
in berufung gehen dem ehemaligen chef
der enthüllungsplattform drohnen in den
usa bis zu 175 jahre haft der vorwurf er
soll dabei geholfen haben geheimes
material zu us militäreinsätzen zu
stehlen seine unterstützer sehen in ihm
einen journalisten der kriegsverbrechen
veröffentlicht machte
vier tage nach der veröffentlichung
einer studie zum sexuellen missbrauch im
bistum münster
hat sich bischof felix genn zu den
vorwürfen geäußert denn räumte fehler
ein lehnte allerdings einen rücktritt ab
und sagte er habe nichts vertuscht zudem
kündigte er konsequenzen an so sollen
personalentscheidungen künftig
transparenter werden und es soll eine
aufarbeitung kommission geben von 1945
bis 2020 gab es im bistum münster laut
der studie 610 jungen und mädchen die
opfer von sexualisierter gewalt durch
kleriker wurden
in schwerin hat ein parlamentarischer
untersuchungsausschuss
seine arbeit aufgenommen der sich mit
der umstrittenen klimastiftung
mecklenburg vorpommern beschäftigen wird
die stiftung sollte sowohl
klimaschutzprojekte als auch die
fertigstellung der deutsch russischen
ostseepipeline nord stream zwei
unterstützen der ausschuss soll unter
anderem die umstände der
stiftungsgründung und die rolle von
ministerpräsident in spe sich klären
zudem welchen einfluss russland namen
und wohin geld aus moskau floss
beantragt hatte ihn die opposition aus
cdu grünen und fdp
mit gedenkveranstaltungen wurde heute an
den ddr volksaufstand vom 17 juni 1953
erinnert in berlin legten die regierende
bürgermeisterin giffey und
bundesbauministerium geiwitz kränze am
mahnmal auf dem friedhof seestraße
nieder heute vor 69 jahren waren in der
ddr etwa eine million menschen auf die
straße gegangen um für bessere
lebensbedingungen und freie wahlen zu
protestieren der aufstand wurde von
sowjetischen militär blutig
niedergeschlagen mehr als 50 menschen
wurden getötet und tausende verhaftet
und täglich grüßt das murmeltier so
heißt die amerikanische filmkomödie über
einen der in einer zeitschleife fest
hängt man fühlt sich daran erinnert
jedes mal wenn der
bundesgesundheitsminister auf diesen
pressekonferenzen richtung herbst voraus
schaut übrigens egal wie der
bundesgesundheitsminister jeweils heißt
es geht immer um sorgenvoller appelle um
warnungen und die ankündigung
vorbereitet zu sein
zu häufig haben wir erlebt wie
unvorbereitet das land dann in die
jeweils nächste welle heute jedoch ist
einiges anders der gesundheitsminister
appelliert zwar wieder sorgenvoll und
kündigt an aber er warnt auch vor panik
und er verspricht diesmal werde einiges
anders sein als bisher frank buchwald
der sommer bricht aus die menschen
genießen die sonne und alle atmen auf
kein wunder nach zweieinhalb jahren
corona das virus aber ist immer noch da
sagt der bundesgesundheitsminister heute
etwa in der bundespressekonferenz
die us daten geben dass zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht her dass man das
verpflichtend machen kann aber wenn man
sich und andere schützen möchte kann
sollte man die maske tragen und das ist
also eine bitte die ich an die
bevölkerung habe dass man sich selbst
und andere hier schützt die aktuellen
virusvarianten omikron vier und fünf
seien zwar ansteckend jedoch weniger
gefährlich sagt der minister und setzt
deshalb auf freiwilligkeit widerspruch
kommt aus den rathäusern ein
freiwilliges gebot ist nett aber hilft
dann an der stelle nicht aber wenn
wirklich die zahl wieder hochschnellen
dann muss eben auch eine kommune
ermächtigt werden solche verpflichtungen
auch anordnen zu dürfen das robert koch
institut erwartet für die kommenden
wochen wieder steigende infektionen
kritik jedoch dass erfasse längst nicht
alle corona fälle weist vizepräsident
schade zurück wir haben für alle
wesentlichen fragestellungen gute daten
man muss diese daten aber eben auch
entsprechend interpretieren und in den
kontext stellen gehen die fallzahlen
runtergehen die fallzahlen hoch da kommt
es jetzt nicht so sehr darauf an ob es
tatsächlich 600 die inzidenz ist oder
oder 495 es kommt auf den trend an für
das kommende jahr hofft minister
lauterbach auf neu entwickelte
impfstoffe die eine ansteckung
vollständig verhindern könnten wir
nähern uns immer mehr den zustand dass
wir auch impfstoffe adoptierte im stoff
für entwickeln können die die
eigentliche ansteckung weg bekommen
werden dann auch eine drohende immunität
in der bevölkerung haben wo also kroner
dann eine krankheit ist wie jede andere
infektionskrankheit wir sind aber jetzt
noch nicht da für den herbst sei damit
noch nicht zu rechnen ältere und
risikopatienten so der minister sollten
sich deshalb schon jetzt
ein viertes mal impfen lassen naja also
empfehle ich die vierte impfung für all
diejenigen die zum einen durch die stiko
empfehlung abgedeckt sind die über
70-jährigen und diejenigen die planer
erkrankungen haben ich würde es aber
selbst auch großzügige handhaben ich bin
zum beispiel selbst auch ein viertes mal
geimpft weil ich habe viele kontakte im
september will lauterbach auch ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz vorlegen mit
einer dann wieder schärferen masken
pflicht einen weiteren anlauf für die
allgemeine impfpflicht werde es jedoch
nicht geben details soll ende juni eine
expertenkommission präsentieren
wir bleiben noch beim thema mit dir und
blicken auf einen der großen
streitpunkte als die korona impfstoffe
weltweit noch sehr knapp waren sollte
der patentschutz für die vakzine
aufgehoben werden oder nicht heute nun
hat die welthandelsorganisation
eine entscheidung dazu getroffen und
sagt die patente können umgangen werden
zumindest temporär allerdings valerie
haller es gibt viel kritik an dem
beschluss und das aus ganz
unterschiedlichen ecken warum genau ja
weil das ist ein kompromiss und findet
man eben immer kritiker auf beiden
seiten der ganz große wurf der ist es
auch tatsächlich nicht denn das ergebnis
liegt deutlich hinter dem ursprünglichen
antrag und dennoch kann wenigstens die
wto ist als erfolg verbuchen jahre lang
wurde über das thema gestritten und die
fronten waren noch ziemlich verhärtet
die freude unter den wto mitgliedern war
groß in genf zum ersten mal seit jahren
hat die handelsorganisation mal wieder
ein abkommen unter dach und fach
gebracht in einem wichtigen punkt des
die einigung geglückt bei patenten auf
corona impfstoffe pharmakonzerne müssen
für eine weile auf ihre patente
verzichten so können auch herstellern
armen regionen wie afrika den impfstoff
massenhaft herstellen den kritikern von
ärzte ohne grenzen und anderen
organisationen geht das abkommen aber
längst nicht weit genug die regelung ist
nur auf bis zu fünf jahre begrenzt auch
komme das abkommen zu spät tatsächlich
gibt es aktuell weit mehr impfstoff als
gebraucht wird und die einigung umfasst
auch nur impfstoffe keine medikamente
und diagnostika auch pharmakonzerne
äußern sich enttäuscht oft den wir
tieren unternehmen jahrelange die
forschung wobei nur ein bruchteil dann
auch wirklich erfolgreich ist der
patentschutz aber der gewährleistet dass
sie mit ihren produkten geld über jahre
verdient das abkommen sagen sie sei ein
gefährliches signal danke valerie nach
frankfurt
und zum tennis davis cup profi oscar
otte hat beim rasenturnier im
westfälischen halle überraschend das
halbfinale erreicht der 28 jährige
gewann im viertelfinale gegen den russen
katchalov und das nachdem er zunächst im
ersten satz verloren hatte morgen trifft
die deutsche nummer zwei dann auf den
weltranglisten ersten mit vegf zu sehen
hier im zdf ab 14 uhr 15
er war einer der großen stars der
französischen film welt nun ist der
schauspieler jean louis trintignant mit
91 jahren verstorben
bekanntheit erlangte er unter anderem an
der seite von brigitte bardot im film
und ewig lockt das weib
1966 kam mit einem mann und eine frau
sein internationaler durchbruch
insgesamt wirkte trotz seniorin mehr als
140 film und fernsehrollen mit und das
auch noch im hohen alter zum beispiel
2012 im preisgekrönten drama liebe
[Musik]
und das war unsere welt an diesem
freitag jetzt wie bereits angekündigt
die spannende neuesten zahlen vom
politbarometer mit matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer es war ein starkes symbol
für die unterstützung der ukraine
bundeskanzler stolz italiens
regierungschef draghi sowie die
präsidenten von frankreich und rumänien
makro und johannes machten sich in kiew
dafür stark dass die ukraine eu
beitrittskandidat wird wie auch die
eu-kommission heute eine mehrheit der
deutschen würde die ukraine gern in der
eu sehen weitere waffenlieferungen auch
ostdeutschland sollen dem land helfen
sich besser gegen den russischen angriff
zu wehren
nur 26 prozent der befragten glauben
dass die ukraine mit hilfe der schweren
waffen aus dem westen den krieg gegen
russland gewinnen kann 64 prozent
glauben das nicht
angesichts der russischen aggression
rückt die nato näher zusammen und wird
für die menschen wieder zu einem
wichtigen faktor so sagte eine klare
mehrheit der deutschen für die
sicherheit der bundesrepublik ist die
nato viel wichtiger geworden und fast
acht von zehn bürgern finden es gut wenn
finnland und schweden dem
verteidigungsbündnis beigetreten
mehr als die hälfte der befragten ist
dafür dass die nato ihre ostflanke in
polen und den baltischen staaten mit
weiteren truppen stärkt 38 prozent sind
dagegen im september 2014 waren die
verhältnisse noch umgekehrt eine
mehrheit sprach sich gegen die
verstärkung der ostflanke aus und da
hatte russland schon die krim annektiert
und den krieg im donbass angezettelt
putins aggression hat also die
wahrnehmung und das denken der menschen
verändert die solidarität mit der
ukraine bleibt groß entsprechend schauen
die bürger auch genau hin wie die
regierung in berlin der in kiew hilft
mit der unterstützung der ukraine durch
die bundesregierung sind 43 prozent der
befragten zufrieden einem drittel ist
das zu wenig und 16 prozent geht die
hilfe zu weit
etwas mehr als ein halbes jahr ist die
ampel regierung jetzt im amt und an
herausforderungen mangelt es nicht
schauen wir auf die parteienlandschaft
in deutschland da zeigt sich derzeit
wenig bewegung wenn am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die spd
auf 22 prozent die union auf 26 prozent
beide unverändert die grünen liegen bei
25 prozent plus 1 die fdp bei 6 prozent
minus 1 die afg bleibt bei zehn prozent
und die linke bei fünf prozent plus 1
von den parteien zu den köpfen hier die
top ten der wichtigsten politikerinnen
und politiker sortiert nach sympathie
und leistung auf der skala von +5 bis -5
schlusslicht christine lambrecht minus
0,7 etwas besser auf platz neun sahra
wagenknecht minus 0,7 verschlechtert
markus söder 0,0 friedrich merz 0,0
beide schlechter platz sechs für
christian lindner 0,1 deutlich
verschlechtert davor karl lauterbach 0,7
cem özdemir 1,1 beide etwas besser auf
platz 3 olaf scholz konstant bei 1,1
annalena baerbock 1,6 schlechter und an
der spitze robert habeck weiter bei 2,1
das thema kosten preise löhne ist für
die deutschen inzwischen das wichtigste
problem noch vor dem ukraine krieg
wenngleich natürlich beides
zusammenhängt
die bundesregierung hat verschiedene
maßnahmen in kraft gesetzt um die bürger
zu entlasten und die werden sehr
unterschiedlich bewertet starten wir mit
dem tank rabatt
dass die mineralölkonzerne den tank
rabatt noch in vollem umfang an die
kunden weitergeben werden glauben mit 8
prozent die allerwenigsten
89 prozent erwarten dass das nicht
passieren wird
die preise auf rekordhoch nicht nur an
den tankstellen mehr als acht von zehn
befragten erwarten dass das nicht das
ende der fahnenstange ist und die preise
noch weiter steigen werden entsprechend
pessimistisch sind die deutschen bei der
beurteilung der wirtschaftlichen
gesamtlage im land nur 22 prozent
bezeichnen sie als gut das sind so
wenige wie seit 2010 nicht mehr etwas
linderung bringen soll das 9 euro ticket
bus und bahn fahren bundesweit war wohl
selten so günstig wie jetzt
fast drei viertel der befragten finden
dass neun euro ticket gut nur 23 prozent
nicht an einen nachhaltigen effekt
glauben aber die wenigsten nur 19
prozent meinen dass auch zukünftig mehr
menschen busse und bahnen nutzen werden
dann wenn es das neuen euro ticket nicht
mehr gibt ab september
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
ersten juli nach dem wetter geht's hier
weiter mit einem heute spezial lutz van
der horst und fabian köster nehmen sich
satirisch die cdu vor einen schönen
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter schauen zurück auf den monat
mai und vor allem in europa war es sehr
warm vor allem im südwesten wenn man
sieht hier die hitze über
nordafrika und das erreichte dann auf
sogar frankreich und dort war der mai
der heißeste und trockenste seit beginn
der wetteraufzeichnung da gab es auch
eine hitzewelle die besonders viel wärme
richtung norden transportiert hat und
diese wetterlage wiederholt sich in
diesen tagen morgen der höhepunkt dann
die hitze von nordafrika über spanien
nach frankreich und nach deutschland
häufig werden wertung und die 40 grad
marke erreicht und auch im westen
deutschlands wird das der fall sein in
der nacht klar ist im westen auf sonst
haben wir mit harmlosen wolken zu tun
temperaturen sinken dabei auf 19 grad im
westen deutschlands und 10 grad im
südosten lüften sie noch mal kräftig
durch denn es wird es morgen heiß werden
ja und das bei viel sonnenschein im
süden sonst harmlose wolken und
weiterhin keinen regen in sicht
temperaturen dazu bis 39 grad im
südwesten teils 38 nach westen hin
örtlich bis 40 grad möglich ganz im
norden ist es erträglicher bei 21 bis 24
grad ja noch einmal 39 grad gibt es dann
am sonntag dazu viel sonnenschein
schauer und gewitter sind dann auch
dabei die können örtlich dann auch
unwetterartig ausfallen ansonsten danach
ist es nicht mehr ganz so heiß damit
einen schönen abend